August 2017, Cassini captured six images of
Enceladus, one of the most intriguing
moons in the solar system.
Enceladus is a relatively small moon of
Saturn.
That's pretty easy to ignore, but once you
pay attention to it, hosts a lot of
surprises.
We've known something was unusual about this
icy world ever since the Voyager mission took
photographs in 1980.
We thought that insolence would be frozen
solid.
And yet we knew from Voyager data the
surface of Enceladus was bright white.
And we could see on the surface that vast
tracts of it were smooth, at least at the
resolution that we had with Voyager.
And that immediately says that there's been
internal activity because that's really on an
airless moon. That's the only process that
could erase craters.
Scientists suspected something was actively
resurfacing Enceladus, filling in its craters
to make it smooth and bright.
Then Cassini sent back pictures of Enceladus
backlit and all was revealed.
We saw these icy jets shooting out from
Enceladus and everyone was so amazed that a
moon so tiny and assumed to be a frozen
solid ice cube could be so active.
Jets have almost luminous material spraying
out of geysers.
When I first saw a picture of a geyser on
Enceladus, I was floored.
That's amazing. I had no idea that that was
even possible.
The Cassini discovery of geysers on Enceladus
was a game changer.
All of a sudden, here's water jetting out.
It was like, too good to be true.
Cassini revealed the geysers are blasting out
liquid water.
Enceladus is not a solid ball of ice.
As we got more data from Cassini, we found
that Enceladus had a wobble that was too
large for a body that was frozen solid all
the way through.
And that told us that a liquid water ocean
circled a rocky core.
Enceladus has liquid water under its surface
and it may very well be an ocean basically
covering the inside of that moon.
But where's the heat coming from?
When planets and moons form, their cores are
incredibly hot.
But over time, they cooled down.
The smaller the planet, the faster it cools.
A tiny world like Enceladus.
Over a billion miles from the sun should
have frozen solid by now.
That's what we expected.
If things are smaller, then they will be
roughly dead and they'd be covered by
craters. But Enceladus shows us that that's
not the case at all.
How could a tiny moon so far from the sun
have enough warmth for liquid water?
One idea is tidal heating.
If you've ever played racquetball, you know,
as you play the game, the ball heats up.
And this is because as the ball hits the
racket or the wall, it's getting squished and
then it relaxes.
Saturn's gravity squishes and relaxes
Enceladus as it orbits the planet, heating it
like a racquet ball.
But this alone wouldn't generate enough heat
to stop and celadus water from freezing.
Something else must be going on in the core.
What if the core of Enceladus is actually
kind of gravelly instead of it just being
solid? It's actually made of rocks and
pebbles and gravel all put together.
Then what happens is as the tides are
stretching and squeezing it, those rocks are
rubbing together and that actually generates
even more energy.
2017. A computer model based on Cassini data
revealed this tidal friction generates more
energy than America's biggest power station.
Water heated to 194°F, rises to the surface.
It sprays through cracks in the moon's South
pole, creating misty plumes.
As we flew seven times through and tasted and
sampled the gas and the particles, we found
salty particles that the ocean was salty,
very much like the Earth's ocean.
We found hydrocarbons.
Methane, carbon dioxide.
When we found the key ingredients for life
coming out of the jets of Enceladus so
remarkable.
In 2018, scientists reanalyzed the Enceladus
data and found something even more
remarkable. Complex organic molecules.
What they found were larger organic compounds
than initially thought there.
At first it was just dust and water and some
some basic organics.
Now they're seeing more complex stuff coming
up from Enceladus interior.
And that asks the question, what else is
down there?
On Earth, we find life huddled around hot
vents on the seabed.
Could the same be true in the oceans of
Enceladus?
Could these complex organic molecules be
signs of life?
My favorite name for them is goo.
They're gooey things, and think of life as a
collection of gooey like molecules.
Now, that doesn't mean that all gooey
molecules are biological, but certainly
biology makes use of these complex organic
molecules.
Deep in Enceladus, oceans, heat from
hydrothermal vents drives chemical reactions,
combining simple molecules like methane and
hydrogen into longer, complex organic
molecules. Complex molecules that could
serve as the precursors to life.
What's amazing is the chemistry of that
ocean.
Everything needed for life is there.
The eternal question is, is there life in the
universe?
And Enceladus is a great place to try and
answer that question.
And Cassini revealed secrets of another moon
of Saturn with amazing chemistry.
A giant moon with earth like features
rivers, lakes and dunes.
Titan.